Oh, that's cutters. I'm just following up with my question about high blood pressure that you
addressed for me last week. I have a drinking pomegranate juice in an effort to bring my blood pressure
down naturally. I see that it's very high in sugar. I know it's natural sugar, but I'm wondering if
in view of my breast cancer diagnosis is that risky for me or maybe it's the risk for taking.
Again, it's, yeah, it has, you know, you're drinking four ounces of pomegranate juice. I don't know
how many milligrams maybe it's 50, 40 milligrams of sugar in that pomegranate juice, but you
we don't want to try to have a good diet to help with your cancer and then you have a diet
heart attack. So it was just an alternative way to help bring down your blood pressure.
Now, if you're a monitor, you're blood pressure at any basis and you're trying to do it,
you know, in similar situations, sitting at the same table, sitting at the same chair,
we need a similar time of day, similar setup, stress issues around at that time. So you're trying
to get as accurate as you possibly can. Remember I said the whole blood pressure cups are not
statistically extremely accurate. So you try to mitigate other variations as well as you possibly can
to get some level of accuracy in the testing. And if you can see your blood pressure dropping
with what you're doing and maintaining a lower level, that's what our goal is.
And then you can back off on the pomegranate juice. Doesn't mean you have to take it all the time.
This need to calm that down. You should be receiving that cheek swab any minute along with the list
of supplements taken. I forgot to include your digest on the list. They also forgot to mention that I'm
doing MMS cancer protocols right now. You don't have to remind me of the clear digest.
Because I did get your cheek swab and I started working on it already. And I did add that,
but I did not add the MMS protocol. So I'll do that. Okay. Thank you for that. So again, when you're
dealing with two different conditions that can be contradictory treatment protocols for those two
different conditions, you do have to kind of weigh out the consequences of each
and depending on where you are. Oh, if you had high blood pressure and your cancer was
growing like crazy. And then I would say, probably not the best thing to do is to do the pomegranate
juice, maybe do blood pressure medication instead. But if your cancer is in relative state of
remission, which yours is, would it be okay to do pomegranate juice for a few
buds to try to get your blood pressure down? I would say that's a reasonable
answer to the question. So again, you're just trying to, you know, we're not trying to follow
rigorous tendencies in our diet or our protocol or our lifestyle. We're trying to be reasonable.
And and weigh out the clothes and tons of each thing. Sometimes you need to change things
for a period of time because you have other core remedies going on and you need to tweak things
and change things for a shorter time and go back to something different. So I've been doing
intermittent fasting for years. So it's not a problem that sometimes I wonder if it's hard on my
needles. Sometimes I feel like headed. You know, if it causes spike in cortisol because blood sugars
get too low. Okay, so if you do intermittent fasting and your blood sugar levels drop,
that can certainly cause like headedness. Now you can see if the like headedness is from blood sugar
levels dropping or if it's from something else by testing with a glucometer. So if you had a whole
glucometer and you feel like headed, good time to do a think of it and to see where your blood sugar
levels are. If they're at like 60 or something like that, then your light headedness is most likely due
to the intermittent fasting. And then probably intermittent fasting is not good
solution for you because you're ending up with a reactive hypoglycemia. So
usually if you talk to people that are really in the fasting, people with diabetes
and or people with hypoglycemia, by doing fasting can help bring that into balance.
But the truth is is that, you know, if you have hypoglycemia and you have, you know, kind of a
chronic condition of a doing intermittent fasting is probably not the thing to do because that is
part of the problem with people with hypoglycemia. They tend to skip meals and they tend to not be
able to keep their blood sugar balanced. So if you have a glucometer at home, that would be the
thing to do to assess it. If you are feeling like headed, do we need a bit faster than you think
you're prepped yourself and tested your blood with a glucometer and it was at ID4, then it's that's
your light-headedness isn't because of or drop in glucose, but it could be something else,
it could be a blood pressure issue, it could be an adrenal issue, it could be, you know, it could be
a lot of other things. You know, it could be an immediate issue and then intermittent fasting
still might not be your solution but you want to dig into what is the cause of that.
So if you're getting light-headed, you'll let her what? If you're doing intermittent fasting or what?
Light-headedness, you want to try to get to the root, you want to try to get to the cause. Again,
one cause of that would be hypoglycemia, another cause of light-headedness could be anemia,
another cause could be drop in your Doritos, especially if you say, like it light-headed when I stand up
from a sitting position and I have to kind of grab the table and it calms down when I'd be able to
walk across the floor or go where I was going, that might go to adrenal insufficiency,
especially if you didn't figure at the time and your blood sugar was with the normal right,
that's what you would think of. So you've got to get to the root of what it is.
So your comment, if you're doing intermittent fasting for years,
it's not a problem for you to do it, but you wonder if it can be
caused of some other symptoms, certainly can't be, then don't do it. It's not something you need to do.
It's just another thing that intermittent fasting can be really good to do with
eye blood sugar. So if they, you know, can't get their blood sugar below 110 or something like that,
you know, in the fasting, you know, longer fasting could be beneficial to help get that down to the balance.